you know in the Modern Age people tend
to be very socially conscious we live in
a culture filled with extremely selfless
and empathetic individuals who are
always looking to get involved in
worthwhile social causes that is just as
long as the cause requires them to
expend little to no effort and
contribute nothing of value to the world
we love to come together for no reason
and rally around nothing to do nothing
at all this is the most popular sort of
activism around and Tik Tok is the best
place to organize these kinds of
charitable Endeavors so here's the
latest a new viral Tik Tok video has
called attention to the scourge of quote
unquote trapped water what is trapped
water well here's a user who goes by the
name spread your dreams explaining uh in
a video that has been viewed now over
three million times and here's what she
says I just picked this up it's a full
bottle of water and I'm on this quest to
dump out any water that gets trapped in
the plastic because once it's trapped in
these plastic bottles we now have lost
it basically forever so it's really
important when you see hi doggo when you
see water that's discarded to open it up
and dump it
out um alternately to make sure that
when you're done with water and that
goes for like you know juices or sports
drinks or what whatever dump that
out if you're not going to use it
because if you don't it's it's trapped
forever and we've lost that water um to
our ecosystem so
thanks uh so there it is the new current
thing free the water if you find a
bottle laying around with liquid inside
dump the liquid on the ground don't even
worry about what the liquid is just you
know dump it on the ground and if you
don't eventually the Earth will run out
of water and this is an idea that may
sound completely insane because it is
but it resonated with the folks on Tik
Tok here are the top comments on that
video somebody named simply Sarah says
not me teaching the water cycle today
but never thinking about this Ken says
trapped water just ruined my day Rachel
eki says I've thought about this every
day since I learned about the water
cycle and this video makes me feel so
validated another comment says we'll now
be anxious about trapped water
forever another one no seriously this
freaks me out all water has to go back
to the rain
cycle yes we must facilitate the water's
Journey back into the rain cycle that's
why I typically what I will do is I'll
bring all of my half empty water bottles
up into the sky in a helicopter and I
empty them directly into a cloud because
that is the safest and most
environmentally friendly strategy I
think the ocean's not going to dry up on
my watch I'll tell you that
but still many Tik tokers are now very
concerned about the trapped water
problem because some random Woman made a
video about it this was followed by a
bunch of other videos from other people
on the platform talking about how
anxious this issue has made them watch
is anybody still thinking about that
lady who is talking about trapped water
in water bottles I thought about it
every day for I don't know 2 weeks now
um makes me very
sad every day she thinks about
water in water bottles now as expected
soon the media joined in Yahoo published
an article with this headline woman
warns about the dangerous phenomenon
that is trapped water they report one
Tik tocker recently created a video T
titled free the water to inform her
viewers about the dangers of Trapped
water and the need to dump out liquids
contained in plastic bottles that aren't
going to be used according to the Texas
water quality Association trapped water
is indeed a big problem in the us alone
we waste 22 million gallons of water
each year in landfills due to trapped
water inside plastic water bottles the
organization wrote on the qet website
quote uh that is 22 million gallons of
water that we will never get back into
the Earth's water cycle organization
went on to point out that fresh water
makes up an extremely small fraction of
all the water on Earth and that there is
no new water being created the water
that exists on our planet in the
atmosphere is all there is that means
that when we effectively take it out of
circulation by trapping it indefinitely
in plastic that decreases the total
water supply for all
life okay now I'm no water export expert
but let me just be the first to say that
this is all a bunch of insane
nonsense and to begin with a small
fraction of the water on Earth is fresh
water yes but a huge fraction is
saltwater and the salt water becomes
fresh water when it
evaporates so water from the ocean goes
up into the sky as a gas and it comes
down as fresh water that's why the rain
is not saltwater even though much of it
is coming from the ocean so that that's
the way it
works and um altogether the Earth holds
about
326 million trillion gallons of water a
typical bottle of water is 16 ounces
which means that there are eight bottles
in every gallon which means that the
Earth has enough water to fill
326 million trillion bottles eight times
and that means it would
take millions of years to even begin to
noticeably deplete the water supply by
leaving water trapped in water bottles
okay we could you could try to do it we
could all band together as a species and
say we want to dry up the oceans with
water bottles and we would just like
spend all day filling water water
bottles from the ocean and it would
still take us millions of years to
achieve
this but actually you couldn't even do
it in a million years because water
bottles will decompose eventually and
they'll decompose in about 500 years and
and and so by the time you get to
millions of years all the water bottles
have decomposed and the water has
escaped and even that is irrelevant
because it's not even true that water
left in bottles will not be able to
escape until the bottle decomposes in
fact if the cap was ever opened then the
water will still evaporate and escape
from the bottle from the cracks you know
where the cap was opened in a
comparatively short amount of time and
if for some reason the bottle was never
opened and yet discarded it will almost
certainly be compacted and crushed at
the landf fill at which point the water
will come out and Escape since roie wave
was overturned the left has lost their
mind making abortion their official
Sacrament but the Grassroots PR efforts
which are now more important than ever
are booming despite the narrative PR
efforts have not gone away in fact
they've increased in number one of the
efforts I support is 40 Days for life
because they're changing hearts and
Minds in blue pro-abortion states with 1
million Volunteers in 1600 cities 40
Days for life holds peaceful vigils
outside abortion facilities 40 Days for
life has opened a record number of
locations since row was overturned and
they've grown in volunteers the success
has come with new unwanted attention
though from the doj 40 Days for Life uh
just made national headlines because
they're suing the doj on behalf of their
volunteer Mark Hal who had his house
raided by the FBI they're going on
offense against our compromise FBI and
doj you can help them fight their
ongoing legal battles and pursue uh free
speech for their volunteers including
markal by giving a tax deductible gift
of any amount at 40 days forlife.com
that's 40 days forlife.com to review it
would be impossible to significantly
deplete the water supply by leaving
water trapped in plastic bottles forever
and it's also impossible to leave water
trapped in plastic bottles forever
anyway because plastic uh May may take a
long time to decompose it is not magical
uh you know indestructible material
however it is not
Eternal at the absolute most it would be
trapped for 500 years which is a long
time but not forever and not nearly
enough time to make a dent in the water
supply but in reality the water in the
bottle that you throw into your garbage
will almost certainly be freed in
traveling back up into the atmosphere in
the form of a gas within the week if not
sooner so everything about this trend
and the logic behind it is false and
stupid and ridiculous and not based in
science or common sense or any notion of
objective reality at all but it gives
people a new thing to pretend to worry
about for a few days and it gives them a
very easy way to pretend that they're
making a difference in the world just
dump out your Gatorade and suddenly
you're saving 8 billion people from
dying of
thirst that doesn't make sense but if
you're very stupid it might make you
feel good about yourself which of course
as we know is all that matters at least
in the minds of the trapped water
crusader
who are all today we must say
cancelled thanks for checking out this
video if you'd like to listen to my full
podcast on the go you can check out the
Matt wall show on Apple podcast Spotify
or wherever you get your podcasts